conectados por una tradición el mundo
Recibió la Navidad pero no todos la
celebraron como se supone que debería
ser en paz nosotros cada combatiente
quiere ver a su familia Pero esta
posibilidad es muy limitada es difícil
entender que estás celebrando en algún
lugar bajo bombardeos no en casa en
Ucrania la mayoría festeja la Navidad
ortodoxa el 7 de enero pero el rechazo a
la guerra los motivó este año a
modificar sus costumbres
este año esta celebración es
especialmente importante para estar lo
más lejos posible de lo que sea que nos
conecte con Rusia para que no tengamos
días festivos en común
en belensis Jordania los turistas y
fieles cristianos asistieron a la
tradicional misa de medianoche en la
famosa iglesia de la Natividad
reverenciada como el lugar donde nació
Jesús las figuras que simbolizan el
nacimiento también tuvieron lugar en
India comunidades cristianas de varias
ciudades acudieron en masa a la
Eucaristía y rezaron alrededor de los
pesebres otros celebraron de una manera
no tan convencional en Berlín Alemania
un grupo de nadadores Recibió la Navidad
desafiando Las bajas temperaturas usando
los típicos trajes de Santa Claus o Papá
Noel mientras que en Australia los
bañistas optaron por condiciones más
cálidas y conmemoraron esta fecha bajo
el ardiente Sol de bombay beach
Es realmente agradable estoy muy
contenta de estar sobre arena blanca en
lugar de nieve y no puedo elegir un
lugar mejor para estar
en distintas partes del mundo Esta es la
primera Navidad que se celebra con total
libertad después de dos años de
restricciones y bloqueos por la pandemia
de covid-19
[Aplausos]